realiza las operaciones y simplifica ok
aquí tenemos tres expresiones racionales
debemos hacer una resta y una suma y
como en el caso de las fracciones para
poder sumar o restar expresiones
racionales debemos encontrar un
denominador común y un buen candidato
para denominador común es el mínimo
común múltiplo de los denominadores y
para encontrar ese mínimo común múltiplo
lo que hacemos es factorizar los
denominadores y luego encontrar una
expresión que tenga todos los factores
que nos interesan bueno vamos a empezar
factor izando los denominadores aquí el
x 5 no hay mucho que hacerle ya no se
puede factorizar entonces vamos a
dejarlo así simplemente se queda como x
+ 5 el 2x menos 10 si se puede
factorizar hay un 2 que puede salir lo
podemos poner como 2 x x menos 5
y x cuadrada menos 25 puede que lo
identifique es como una diferencia de
cuadrados
de esta forma x cuadrada menos 25 déjame
ponerlo mejora si se puede factorizar
como x + 5 x x menos 5 muy bien entonces
ya tenemos factor izados los
denominadores ahora hay que encontrar el
mínimo común múltiplo déjame poner por
acá una línea para para fracción
entonces nuestro mínimo común múltiplo
debe tener a x + 5 debe tener un 2 debe
tener a x menos 5 y ax más 5 y x
pero esos ya los contamos aquí de esta
forma el mínimo común múltiplo es 2 x x
menos 5 x x + 5 y esto ya tiene todos
los factores verdad tiene el x5 este 2
este x menos 5 y el x + 5 x x menos 5 de
acá muy bien entonces ahora debemos
pasar estas fracciones a fracciones que
tengan este
va a ser una por acá es otra
ahí van dos y hay una tercera por acá
tres y todas estas deben tener a 2 2 x x
menos 5
por x 5 como numerador aquí también 2
por x 5 por x 5 por x 5 puede que
después ya puedas hacer todo de golpe
sin tener que poner las tres fracciones
pero ahorita lo vamos a hacer paso a
paso para entender que está sucediendo
que está sucediendo poco a poco sale
bueno entonces primero debemos pasar
esta fracción a que tenga denominador 2
por x menos 5 x x + 5 entonces la
pregunta es por cuánto se multiplicó x +
5 para pasar a esta expresión bueno pues
se multiplicó por 2 por x menos 5
entonces eso debe quedar en el numerador
verdad aquí sería estamos multiplicando
voy a poner una flechita así el
denominador lo estamos multiplicando por
dos x menos 5 2 x 5
de modo que el numerador también hay que
multiplicarlo por 2 x menos 5 muy bien
ya eso tenemos que restar vamos a este
término de acá este término es
bueno en el denominador tenemos 2 x x 5
pero acá es 2 x x 5 x x 5 entonces en
este caso se multiplicó el denominador
por x 5
se multiplicó por x 5 x + 5 de esta
forma el numerador también se debe
multiplicar por x + 5 entonces
multiplicamos aquí hay un 2 en el
numerador y eso hay que multiplicarlo
por x + 5 muy bien vamos con el tercero
con la tercera expresión racional esta
la voy a hacer en color azul y vamos a
preguntarnos una vez más por cuanto se
tuvo que multiplicar el denominador para
pasar a 2x menos 5 por x + 5 bueno pues
ya teníamos x 5 y x
simplemente lo multiplicamos por 2 así
que el numerador también se tiene que
multiplicar por 2 como es 2x pasa a ser
4 4x y este y este de aquí lo estamos
sumando bueno pues vamos a efectuar las
operaciones a ver qué nos queda aquí
estamos restando esta fracción así que
déjame mejor pensarlo como que estamos
sumando su inverso
su inverso muy bien entonces vamos a ver
cuánto nos quedan déjame poner aquí en
la línea para separar numerador y
denominador nos quedaría 2 x x menos 5 x
x x + 5 ok entonces vamos con este de
aquí este que está en verde es 2 x x
menos 5 que es 2 x 2 x menos 2 x 5 10
quedaría 2 x menos 10 ahora debemos
sumar menos 12 x lo voy a poner en rojo
menos 2 x menos
2x y luego menos 2 por 5 sería menos 10
menos 10 y finalmente debemos sumar
estos 4x
+ 4 x 4 x vamos a simplificar esto de
aquí es igual a déjame tomar el color
amarillo abajo nos queda 2 x x menos 5 x
x 5 x 5 y arriba nos queda pues vamos a
ver 2 x se cancela con menos 2x y nos
queda 4 x menos 20 4x voy a seguir en
color azul menos 20 esto lo podremos
simplificar todavía más pues a ver 4 x
menos 20 tiene un factor 4 en común
entonces 4 x menos 20 osea el 4 y el 20
tiene un factor 4 entonces lo podemos
poner como 4
4 x x menos 5 y al factorizar la
expresión nos damos cuenta que x 5
aparece en el numerador y en el
denominador de modo que podemos
cancelarlo lo cancelamos y nos queda
simplemente a mira también podemos
cancelar este 4 con este 2 4 entre 2 es
igual a 2 y ahora si nos queda
simplemente esto de aquí es igual a en
el numerador nos queda un 2 ya nada más
queda un 2 y en el denominador queda x +
5 lo voy a poner en amarillo 2 entre x +
5 muy bien y con esto logramos realizar
las operaciones y simplificar pero bueno
me gustaría ser cuidadoso con una cosa
que que usualmente no se descuidados en
las clases de de esto de álgebra aquí lo
que hicimos fue cancelar este x menos 5
con este x menos 5 pero para poder hacer
eso necesitamos que x sea distinto de 5
es decir para que realmente esta
expresión y la expresión con la que
empezamos sean equivalentes debemos
cuidar
se preserva esto de que x sea distinto
de 5 es decir debemos mantener el
dominio el dominio de la expresión
original déjame ponerlo aquí a la
derecha observa que el dominio lo voy a
poner así dominio
de esta expresión son todos los valores
de x excepto aquellos que hagan que esta
expresión quede indefinida a aquellos en
los cuales estamos dividiendo entre 0
entonces sería todos los valores de x
todos los reales los reales reales x
excepto excepto
x igual a 5 x 5 o equis igual a menos 5
sale entonces observa en esta expresión
no podemos poner menos 5 porque aquí
dividiríamos entre 0 y 5 porque aquí
dividiremos entre 0 pero aquí ya
perdimos esta información si solo vemos
a esta expresión como 2 entre x + 5
parecería que sólo necesitamos pedir que
x sea distinto de menos 5 pero nosotros
queremos que esta expresión sea
exactamente igual a ésta entonces aquí
debemos hacer la aclaración de que el
dominio
es todos los reales x
los reales los reales
x excepto excepto
menos 5 excepto menos 5 con esto con
esto nos aseguramos que aquí no
dividamos entre 0 pero también debemos
evitar excepto cinco excepto menos 5
comen con evitar menos 5 evitamos que
aquí dividamos entre 0 pero también
debemos evitar x igual a 5 debemos
evitar x igual a 5 para que esta
expresión realmente sea equivalente a
esta expresión de acá bueno entonces
realizando las operaciones y
simplificando nos queda dos entre x 5 y
para que las dos expresiones sean es
exactamente lo mismo para que sean
equivalentes
debemos pedir que el dominio sea todos
los reales x excepto menos 5 y 5